TRYING TO GET AROUND ROMANOV.OV
THAT AS ANTICIPATION.
HIS SPEED AND HIS STICK WORK TO
GET A REAL GOOD CHANAN
PLAYED IT OFF.
HERE'S HOFFMAN,ALL ON THE ICEAV
ANYTHINGNG, 2009.S IT OUT.
TREVOR VAN RIEMSDYK BITES ON
ITMENT AND AS SOON ASS
BEHIND HIS OWN NET.
PLAYED IT UP
ORLOV, AND THE BUMP BY ELLER IN
THE ZONE AND THAT CATCHES
ROMANOV, HE'S STANDING UP ON ST.
LARS ELLER, AHEAD FOR MANTHAHANT
IT AND THAT LED TO THE DOWD GOAL
AND NOW YOU IT ENDS
UP IN THE NET AT THE OTHER.
>> John: BOTH LOVING IT.
BEAUTIFUL PLAY BY PETRY,
TURNOVER IN THE NEUTRAL KUZNETS.
KUZNETSOV UP TOREALLY
MONTEMBEAULT PLAYS THAT ACROSS
FORR
GALLAGHER TRYING TO GET IT IN
A PUCK IS GOING TO GET CENTERED
INTO THE MIDDLE OF THE ICE AND I
BELIEVE IT GOES OFF THE STICK
DVORAK.
HANDS IT OFF TO MANTHA.ONT, HASM
MANTHA IN TIGHT FOR JOHANSSON.
PETRY. FILM THAT THEY LOSE
PLAYERS COMING OFF THE WALL INTO
THE MIDDLE OF THE ICE
OPPORTUNITY FROM BACKSTROM.YOU
RIGHT PLACE AT THE